Speaker 1: Ginni Thomas, the wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas, now says that
she regrets all of those texts about the 2020
election.
We're going to look at her latest claims.
But I think it's important to remind you,
Ginni Thomas really is like Cunanan level
out of her mind.
I want to remind you of a text message that
Ginni Thomas, again, remember the wife of
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas, who
had issues come before him related to the
2020 election.
Ginni Thomas texted Mark Meadows once, quote,
Biden Crime, family and ballot fraud coconspirators,
elected officials, bureaucrats, social media,
censorship managers, fake stream media reporters
are being arrested and detained for ballot
fraud right now and over the coming days and
will be living in barges off of Guantanamo
Bay to face military tribunals for sedition.
Folks that's Q anon level insane and with
with this barges off of Gitmo thing I always
go back to.
If they're on a barge, why does it have to
be off the coast of Gitmo?
And if it's near Gitmo, why does it have to
be on a barge?
Why wouldn't they just be there?
Of course.
Remember, this wasn't happening factually.
It wasn't happening.
There were no Biden crime family coconspirators
being arrested and detained.
They didn't put them on a barge.
They didn't put them on a cruise ship.
They didn't put them on a dinghy.
They I mean, maybe incidentally, some of them
were on boats at some point in time.
This quite literally didn't happen.
This is just one example of how bonkers this
woman is.
Okay.
She now says she regrets it.
A new report, Yahoo! News, just a couple of
days before New Year's.
Ginni Thomas, the conservative activist and
wife of Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas,
told the January six committee she regretted
the text messages and emails she sent in the
aftermath of the 2020 election to Mark Meadows,
Trump's former Trump's then chief of staff.
According to a newly released transcript of
her September interview with the committee.
Thomas said she regretted the fact that the
messages became public.
Now that's very different.
I apologize because what I said was wrong.
I apologize if anyone was offended.
Well, those are two very different things.
Thomas told congressional investigators, quote,
I don't know how many of you would want your
texts to become public on the front page of
The Washington Post.
Certainly, I didn't want my emotional texts
to a friend released and made available.
Remember that in the messages, Ginni Thomas
urged Meadows to make sure Trump did not concede
to Biden and parroted many of the falsehoods
and conspiracy theories that were spreading.
Among the more fringe claims pushed by Thomas
was the baseless theory among QAnon that Trump
watermarked mail in ballots to track fraud
and a claim circulated on right wing websites
that in Thomas's retelling.
As I told you, the Biden crime family is being
sent to barges off the coast of Gitmo.
This is truly cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
And my concern is people are allowed to be
crazy.
That's not new.
People are allowed to be unhinged.
Conspiracy theorists.
We have tens of millions of them in the United
States.
Many of them voted for Trump in 2020.
The issue is the proximity to Clarence Thomas,
who was involved in adjudicating elements
related to that election.
And I guess we're meant to believe that Ginni
Thomas and Clarence Thomas never talked about
this.
She believed Biden crime, family conspirators
were on barges, but she just never mentions
it to Clarence Thomas.
That is very difficult to believe.
And so, of course, the concern is really Clarence
Thomas and what is one of the most radical
right Supreme Courts and arguably one of the
most partizan supreme courts.
Oh, I know they're nonpartisan.
They simply look at the law and they relate
that to the facts, and they render a completely
unbiased political opinion, a legal opinion.
Obviously, we know that that's not the case.
That's really the concern.
And that appears to be beyond the purview
of what was the January six committee, which,
remember, is done because a new Congress is
sworn in today.
Scary that she's that nuts, but also scary
that she is that close to one of the most
powerful nine justices in the United States
who heard cases related to that very election.
We'll have more on these text messages on
our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman.
Show depressing stuff, I will tell you.